[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à entrer dans
les profondeurs de l'enfer
nat
non mais t'es sérieuses dès lors c'est
halloween
j'ai des pass vip pour le hellfest c'est
quoi ça on se fait peur toute la nuit
dans des labyrinthes tout le monde
flippe sa race
on va s'éclater pourquoi on signe une
décharge pour éviter les problèmes
ils sont obligés il ya deux ans une
fille a été complètement éventrées le
tueur la laisser dans le parc elle
restait là trois jours les gens
croyaient que c'était un mannequin ya
des malades
il se balade pas remis
bon on a compris
tu crois que tu me fais peur non bougez
plus tu as l'air d'avoir peur pluies
vont venir vers toi au cul la joue cool
mais moi si
c'était trop tordu sava l'air tellement
réel
[Musique]
ce qui nous a suivis toute la soirée ok
tu prends ton boulot trop au sérieux
franchement c'est pas drôle
vous êtes venus pour avoir peur non je
vais pas arrêter les gars parce qu'ils
font leur boulot
bienvenue au hellfest